we have a tragic story to share with you
from Charlotte North Carolina today
where a helicopter crash has taken the
lives of two members of the CBS family
meteorologist Jason Myers and pilot chip
tyag worked with our local affiliate
there that's WBTV and their colleagues
are mourning them today Mark straussman
reports they may have been trying to
save lives even as they lost their own
both of them were unbelievable people
and we're gonna we're gonna miss them so
much back to you shock and grief both
palpable as wbtv's news team announced
live that two of their colleagues had
been killed sky 3 carried meteorologist
Jason Myers and pilot chip tayak for
reasons still unclear it crashed midday
Tuesday right next to Interstate 77 in
Southwestern Charlotte the city's police
chief said eyewitnesses reported the
chopper looked in distress and tayag
seemed to Pilot it away from Highway
Traffic below before Crash Landing that
pilot is a hero to in my eyes he was the
consummate pro tyag had flown for more
than 20 years the last five with WBTV
the married pilot preached Safety First
a little chilly out here a lot of fun
and meteorologist Myers seen here in a
report just two days ago was a HomeTown
boy three years ago he took a job in the
WBTV weather Department the same station
he had watched as a kid he leaves a wife
and four children when the news broke
this afternoon I was literally in shock
you know Al Conklin thanks wbtv's chief
meteorologist worked closely with both
men I've been here almost 30 years and
I've never had a day at this station
like this before it's tough really tough
for CBS mornings I'm Mark Strassman
um
I can't imagine what WBTV is feeling
today we're certainly thinking of you
especially to lose colleagues that you
know and worked with and love and loved
and really actually liked and got along
well that's tough and to hear he has
four children is very difficult and and
in the end still apparently trying to
save lives of others yeah selfless
thinking about our colleagues also about
their families especially the holidays
now yes yes